so i posted an instagram photo the other
day of my foot oh yeah uh my my bare
foot up
on uh on my bathroom counter and i got a
dm from some like burner account had
zero posts and like two followers they
asked me if i would be willing to sell
photos of my feet
yeah 20 bucks a pop how about it
[Music]
okay i don't care it's just my feet
and uh they replied and said how about
uh yeah here i've got the um i've got
the dm right here
are you interested in selling me
pictures of your feet and i said 20 each
what's your currency usd yes and then
they said my offer is 500 bhd for six
pictures and two videos equals 1.3 uh
holy [ __ ] thirteen hundred bucks so i
was like all right and i said it's so
old
wait wait wait wait wait this was look
at what time it was seven in the morning
yeah damn this feet guy wakes up this
was on wednesday what is bhd uh bahrain
so i asked if he was in bahrain and he's
like yeah and i said so are you just a
person in bahrain who's into this and
he's like yeah just a guy out here and
what's the next uh also the worst
negotiator in the world twenty dollars a
pop i'll give you thirteen hundred i
didn't i didn't stop to do the math i
was like oh that's way more but yeah
that's probably legit and i can't
[ __ ] believe that you're actually
taking this guy up on this well because
at this point i'm just curious i said
i'm not gonna do anything nude and he
said but i didn't ask for nude content
did i and i said no you didn't you dude
uh so i said how will you send the money
you said how do you prefer i said paypal
good what time and will you take the
pictures and i said you know well i
expect payment first like give me half
the money i'll send you half the phone
you're [ __ ] negotiating with this so
then he said that's how payment works
you send half three pictures in one
video and then i pay and then you send
the other three in the other video and i
said all right
so he said
wait that's not me that's not me yet
these are the angles for the pictures
and videos wait everyone shut up
my
[ __ ] soul just left my body i want to
crawl
i don't know i don't know who that guy
is please tell me you didn't [ __ ] do
this i did no
wait wait wait i want to crawl out of my
skin dude i want to cross
wait just listen to me listen don't hate
me don't judge me
oh my
god so then i said
i got listen listen just wait a second
wait a second all right look here's the
video look
i don't want to see the [ __ ] video
it's not a big deal it's not a big deal
yes it is no it's not i'm like laughing
i'm like all right what the [ __ ] all
right
here we go
[Laughter]
wait well there's one more position i
gotta get in no not look look i'm not
naked i'm not naked i'm not making a
fake
i'm not doing anything
hey hey all right i thought i was gonna
get thirteen hundred dollars oh
oh i thought i was gonna get thirteen
hundred dollars wait
so that's it no i'm not doing anything
i'm not doing anything
wiggle the wiggle those little pigs i
wiggled them a little bit with those
little piggles
i wiggled them a little because i
thought you know and there's the last oh
my god dude oh
my god
so what happened
dude
ben
yeah what the [ __ ] i can't believe hey
baby it's nine in the morning anything
goes oh my god i had my matcha in my oh
my god i also came home you downplayed
this before we started we're like yeah i
got a little i got a little story and
we're like well we know we know it's
good because your stories are normally
good you guys no it'll be it'll be quick
do you see what brand of shorts i'm
wearing bird dogs yeah they're birds
dude next time do you guys do now do you
guys do ads for this we did one i think
we're going to lose them after this no
no you got you got to just use these and
be like look how comfortable they are
look how agile i am in my bird dog is
some guy from bahrain trying to rip you
off
well wait so then what happened i sent
through the video and he said okay
what's your paypal and i'm like [ __ ]
yeah cool all right and then he said i
gave him my paypal and then he said end
the picks and i said you want the same
angles as the video he didn't respond so
i just sent through the photos and then
something really fast happened he
double-clicked and liked all of them and
then
the last thing i said was hello
come on man
guess what the account's gone now like
almost instantly it was like profile not
found so this guy's got three pictures
of my feet in the video of my feet and
so you know what we're doing we're
flooding the market
we're driving down the value of those uh
oh
[ __ ] my god bro okay so just hear me oh
my god
you're sitting here making jokes i've
even [ __ ] processed what dude i know
i just want to go back run it back run
it i couldn't look like i was crying
it's not a big deal look look i'm just
like all right
this is the biggest deal this is insane
all right you know i'm just chilling
there and then all right the look off
camera
and i put my head down because i'm like
you know maybe i shouldn't have my head
in this
stop and pause it right there
wait look at how you move your feet
looking directly through his legs at the
camera just
oh
just because i i can hear like your
inner monologue like oh better wiggle my
toes
that's pretty much exactly what i was
thinking i
[Laughter]
can i have can i have this for my iphone
background
you can take it man for my lock screen
it'll be uh 10 bhd oh
my god okay i i gotta say i'm not naked
i'm not making any kind of weird faces
i'm not making any sounds i'm simply you
know as far as i'm concerned these are
yoga positions yeah so that's how i
justified it yeah thank you see he gets
it he said he would he would do it right
yeah yeah that's what he said pretty
much definitely not what i said
see that one that one is so emasculating
dude yeah that one is well that's right
well you see i then put both arms out
which is a very strong pose
it's like i'm checking on a fireplace
well watch go to the go to the picture
of that one yeah dude the picture of
that one is a lot more masculine yeah no
you're you're you're looking under yeah
see look at your card i'm taking under a
it's the beauty of the internet wow
anyway i really hope you guys don't
think less of me i i
i gotta be honest i do
i'm just dying laughing at him sending
those
grim
dark ass images of that strange man just
like
yeah
and you were like i could do that
yeah and i was like i'm keeping my shirt
on because the guy had his shirt off
peeking above your crotch like this
yeah i'm glad i'm not high right now i
can hear i can hear ben's voice yeah you
want to get on zoom or something just to
make sure we get it right
make sure you're real should i set up
some lights or something or i'm just
pissed that i got taken like you never
that's the most you always get paid
first right i know but i thought well
because he you know what's funny he said
yeah send the pictures first i've been
burned before and i'm like oh you [ __ ]
you burned me you reached out to me yeah
yeah yeah
god i was having a really good morning
and i was just like feeling good and
like yeah nothing could do in my life
yeah i'm already i was having a good day
in stocks and i was just like hey what's
another 1300 bucks let's do it baby see
this stuff like 1300 stock market is a
poison yeah the stock market makes you
feel good make you feel so good you'll
[ __ ]
send a stranger your [ __ ] feet for
money all it takes is one yeah i'll take
this one good trade and you're like
[ __ ] it dude how was this this is hustle
culture baby
this is what day trading is about
what how how was the negotiating don't
do that anymore it was like
he put his feet up on the table dude
i can't see it the same
i don't judge you thank you
this this to me is just a very ben story
gonna be my legacy when i when i
leave this portal it says a lot about
your self-worth because if someone said
to me thirteen hundred dollars for your
feet picks i'd say come on you don't
want that this is insane but you were
like i'm worth it yes
that's exactly right immediately these
these feet are worth yeah thirteen
hundred dollars also nothing is forever
i'm gonna be dead in like [ __ ] 100
years and it'll be something for someone
some [ __ ] kid before he's about
all right what should we move on from
the nude i don't think i'm gonna be
thinking about it as i go to sleep
that's fine you know it's really we all
are like all 100 000 people
listening to this are going to go to
sleep and just remember ben just like
yeah but those are so like the
vulnerability of like you kind of you
could see it in your face if kind of
like looking at the camera like i hope
this is what he's looking for it's just
very beautiful i was trying to look at
that way beautiful i was trying to look
that way in the event that it would get
out somehow
little did i know i would just gladly
offer it up but i was like yeah because
i'm not gonna be like
[ __ ]
although that probably would have made
it better peter parker moment oh
ben
no
uncle ben
don't show your feet to that man in
bahrain
fine peter this will pay the rent
most people are joking about the foot
fetish but there are a few who uh
nah for sure bro there was a there was a
woman also in my dm's in in canada i
think also on a burner account asked me
for a couple and she's she was a real
person i could tell wow did you get that
asking for feed pictures yep
and you didn't i didn't didn't give it
to her nope
but the bahrainian man
some reason was
1300 is a much different i learned my
bargaining actually i think she was
asking me for like three for like i
don't even remember uh 40 bucks or
something i was like sorry sweetie it's
one for 20. yeah but these were loons
probably
loons isn't that what they call them
what canadian money oh yeah uh loonies
oh yeah loonies we got the loonies and
then we got the toonies
yeah but wait wait wait three for how
many uh 40.
i think 40 per currency uh no us dollars
i think oh so it's like 1 000
loonies no the exchange rate's not that
yeah yeah no it's like monopoly money
yeah it's not real
but i need to hit her
oh you know what i told her i said
they're going to be free in a few days
just wait can we move on yes i'm sorry
we're almost at 40 minutes
[Laughter]
yeah if you're out there somehow pal
reactivate your account and dm ben just
give it a shot i mean
i'm not gonna try to shake you down for
the money because what can i do right so
no no we don't want money yeah we want
to interview you yeah you can be
anonymous completely yeah we need to
know your process
i should put out an instagram story with
just text and be like to the bahrainian
man please dm me we want to interview
you yeah you should and he's like i'm
not bahrainian you idiot i'm from
minnesota i just tricked you yeah you
got [ __ ] got yeah but then he
wouldn't have deleted his account he
would have taunted me and been like you
[ __ ] idiot oh he might have not
completed his whole thing he's like okay
i've compiled the pictures i'm gonna do
a fun edit we're really gonna dunk on
this guy what did ninja do okay sorry
sorry sorry
can i just get this dumbass sketch off
my chest i'm just imagining ben
some years later in bahrain he you know
he's just walking in public he's kind of
like uh
this brings back bad memories he pushes
it out trips on something in public
falls forward his [ __ ] feet come out
of his sandals and so his bare feet just
hit the pavement and he's in that all
fours position in a public square and
everyone there is just like
it's him
and then you you look back like huh and
they all roll you on your back and they
lift your legs up and they're like look
through your legs
you're like like this you're like
he said it
and i become the king of bahrain yeah
hell yeah
they're like thank god you're here can
you please give me my 500 bahrainian
dollars now please